I'm always amazed by how scientists and
engineers outsmart the natural world
one thing that may happen is that you're
targeted to a specific goal but you may
end up doing something else so if you
observe something that looks promising
you have to be able to take it
Hamilton Smith's initial work that led
to the Nobel Prize was restriction
enzymes and that allowed manipulation of
DNA which opened up a whole new field of
cutting and cloning and analyzing DNA
and the sequencing DNA being able to
take an organism and say what's its
blueprint that's an entirely new way of
thinking and led to the Human Genome
Project
I wanted to ask you about the recent
paper that's just been published online
with Craig Ventnor about the synthetic
cell so this was a large technical
challenge it seems to just make the DNA
you know this size
yeah it's it's a technical achievement
there will be a lot of science coming
out of the applications of what we've
done but right now it's a technical
achievement to put together 1.1 million
base pairs correctly from starting with
just a sequence and synthesized with
four chemicals a G C and P we're here
today to announce the first synthetic
cell a cell made by starting with the
digital code and the computer building
the chromosome from four bottles of
chemicals assembling that chromosome
eight yeasts transplanted it into a
recipient bacterial cell and
transforming that cell into a new
bacterial species this is the first
self-replicating species that we've had
on the planet whose parent is a computer
so would it be fair to say that you
downloaded the genetic code and printed
it on a very expensive printer to make a
big molecule a cell like and then booted
it up yeah that's right Craig likes to
say that we've been sequencing genomes
now we're writing them so for
individuals that might be worried that
you're creating a new bacteria that has
new and different properties what would
you say about I would say not to worry
well what we've done now is simply to
make some minor changes in an existing
organism it's not dangerous to humans we
can work in the laboratory quite safely
with it it's also a very delicate
organism if I put some out in the grass
here it would die it only lives in in
goats
so if goats should be worried but not me
yeah and they shouldn't be worried
because we can treat it yeah
but how did you come about with the idea
of building a synthetic cell was it just
to strip it down or did you do you want
to create more complex structures as
well or do you want to make a factory to
make biofuels one day I think once we
have a minimal cell we want to start
adding different things to it to make it
a more complex so for example a pathway
that would make a useful fuel or a
pharmaceutical product or whatever he
was interested very much and what I've
been doing with synthetic cells I think
partly because he's trying to see how it
might be helpful in his own work what
motivates us is almost the science
fiction of autonomous medical tools
Fineman talked about surgical micro
robots that you could swallow the
surgeon and it would make decisions and
cut out a cancer things like that so
we're trying to demonstrate some of the
tools that may be useful to build some
of these things so we build little micro
grippers that are about a millimeter in
diameter that start out flat and when we
want them to be triggered they can
trigger and grab something and we've
shown we can do a little in vitro
biopsies so these are very small robotic
things that would be introduced attached
to a very thin wire well that's what
makes them very interesting they're
Teves oh really
yeah so one of the initiatives gets into
some of the long-term challenges and
making these sorts of things we need
them to either carry their energy on
board or be able to extract energy from
the environment and in order to actuate
so the beautiful part is their tether
las' and we build them out of thin metal
films and polymers we can build nickel
into them and nickel is magnetic and so
we can control them outside with a
magnet and move them around really long
so I can bring it over to a place and
then be a trigger I can actuate it and
what I've been leading is trying to get
them to respond to bio chemicals choose
biochemical interest
interactions before we have to use heat
or nasty solvents like acetone or acids
or things like that to trigger them to
make this polymer change its properties
and what I've just submitted for
publication what I've shown is that I
can get into
to enzymes if we can get it incredibly
selective to say a disease marker uh-huh
I think one of our dreams is maybe then
it could sense some move towards that
thing once it founded it with your
operating absolutely yeah so that's
that's really it's getting incredible I
say it's it's pretty yeah we just I work
on it for months and you kind of lose
sight of it the fact that you're with
his latest work it's a real
technological feat these are not
questions that seek to answer the
fundamental nature of the universe or
whether things may be possible or not
but really about you know if we want to
do something how do we go about doing it
and that relates to my work because we
have this science fiction dream that we
want to turn into a reality
so I've often thought of what I do is
falling into one of two slots there's
the type of scientists or engineers that
seek to understand things and those that
seek to build things and it's a very
different way of thinking in the lab and
it sounds like you're doing a bit of
both it's a little bit of both I don't
know what would be a good analogy I
always think of a car engine I guess if
if you can take it apart and put it
together I think you get a better
understanding than just opening the hood
yeah that was my childhood story of
taking things apart and putting them
together the difference I was head parts
left over so yeah but things still work
so I guess they were non-essential well
there you are you're leaving out its
non-essential parts yeah you're already
playing the game yeah but I don't think
I should be a surgeon Fineman says you
know what we cannot create we cannot
understand so you know we're taking that
lesson we're still at the stage of fully
understanding what nature is produced at
the cell level and we're starting really
with the simplest bacteria just like
early molecular biologists started with
the very simplest viruses to study we
thought that if we go to a very small
cell with a small genome
first of all the genome is small enough
that we could probably synthesize it and
then at some point we could use our
synthetic a cell approach to build sense
synthetically build a genome that's even
smaller where we specifically leave out
the genes that are not essential for
growth in the laboratory they might be
essential for the growth in the
environment but under specific
conditions in the laboratory you can
dispense with a lot of things so taking
the air-conditioning out of the car and
right see how little new can drive
around yeah so we want to get down
really just to the very basic machinery
of the cell so what one thing I was
thinking of is is with the miniaturized
tools that that our lab is developing
right now there are metals and polymers
but being able to integrate a living
factory on it if I could use the tool to
guide itself to a site where there's
disease and then have an engineered cell
or an engineered factory to produce
antibiotics or anti-cancer agents Jutta
and turn it on just what I want is
nothing for example of toxin against the
specific cancer absolutely could be
transported that way and that way you
wouldn't be giving that toxin the
chemotherapy agent systemically and
there'd be less side effects and you
might be able to deliver it into a
difficult area like deep inside the
liver do you think that's something that
one day they a technical challenge you
know we can put together the right parts
and keep working on it okay something
I'll keep it's very cutting yeah I think
some of what hammersmith does is similar
to what I do i I dream of a system I say
oh this should be easy and in reality we
find out it's difficult and we have one
technical challenge after another but
it's it's exploring the unknown with a
final goal of building something I work
in a very interdisciplinary lab we have
chemists and physicists and engineers
and electrical electronics people and
everyone has a different point of view
we get to a group meeting and you know
by the time and the electrical engineer
asks the chemists to explain their
reaction the chemist thinks of something
new and goes back downstairs and tries
out yeah that's good I think one of the
most important things is to let students
conceive of their own ideas and be able
to pursue them rather than being told to
do something so can I ask it would you
consider yourself an engineer in
practical terms and how you are building
synthetics out this was a very I'm glad
to hear that as an engineer who were in
the right feel fantastic thing to hear I
think it's very important that engineers
are included in worldwide scientific
conferences and events like the lindau
meeting and I'm very proud that a few
there are a few engineers like myself
here because we I feel that we really
contribute to the development of science
we really see everything as a problem to
be taken apart and put back together and
solved and if you get us engineers
excited about something we just love to
play everything he's doing is new to me
I had no idea that people were working
on this very interesting talking to us
you